under the United States Constitution
Congress makes the laws and the
president enforces the laws a law
provides Authority for the president and
the agencies of the government to compel
individuals corporations and others to
take or not to take certain acts for
example a law authorizes the President
to collect taxes through the Internal
Revenue Service neither the president
nor the IRS can collect taxes or do
anything else without a supporting law
from Congress however the laws leave the
IRS and other agencies with discretion
on how they enforce the law an executive
order is the president's written
direction to the agencies of the
government about how he wants them to
act when they enforce the law for
example President Trump issued an
executive order directing all agencies
to eliminate two regulations for every
regulation the issue as long as the
order is consistent with the
Constitution and the law the president
can use an executive order to tell the
IRS and others how he wants them to do
what Congress has authorized our
executive orders by President Trump a
good idea let us know in your comments
and also let us know what other topics
you want a EEI scholars to cover in 60
seconds